Do you think it's prudent to send homemade to somebody when you've
only known them for 10 days? Yes or no? You're so full of [__]
It's mind-blowing. >> Connor, I have never in my >> Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. We could just watch your content for the last 6 months
and see you running away from your own talking points. How many
friends do you have left, by the way? At what point do you go,
"Oh, [__] IT'S ME."
BUT YOU ARE SUCH A
THAT IT IS impossible to be your friend. It's impossible to be
your partner. It is impossible to tell you that you're wrong.
It's impossible for you to take a
>> So, if you guys missed it, Counter-Points had a stream
today and he was talking to Destiny and then I think that eventually
Destiny hops on and
it goes it goes pretty crazy. There's a lot of fighting back
and forth and Destiny will make a point of, "Okay, well, when
Destiny doxes people, he's putting people's family at risks and
he's like creating what we would call permission structure or
a a possible lens by which people will judge him and act against
him, right? That well, we principally don't
is sort of losing his moral high ground to say people should
defend me against these these kinds of actions, right? >> But
I I think that this situation is actually quite serious and you
are thinking about like complete disassociation for me and Wick.
>> It's not serious. Connor, this is not a serious conversation
and I'm not I want to I want to say I'm sorry. I'm being honest.
Like, that's that opinion is so immediately stupid. I'm not even
going to pretend to have a conversation with you. It's I'm not
going to have you say that after you and I have had a five going
on six-year relationship that you get to deem a topic undeserving
of your time, attention, or conversation.
That's not happening. >> Well, they think THAT YOU USE
YOUR SEXUAL POWER AND CLOUT AND influence and money in in order
to mentally women.
>> Give me one example.
Anna Vor. You're saying that he's creating this stochastic permission
structure through which you can be doxxed and harassed and since
you're being doxxed and harassed, you have the right to dox him.
So, so hold on. You think Jay Stock, Queen Man, E-Sports Batman,
they all hate you for delusional or non-serious reasons.
>> Uh I >> That's crazy. >> Okay, dude. >> Hey,
so uh going back to the food truck thing, could you guys want
to explain why you guys don't like each other or what's the >> Yeah,
shouldn't off to kids. >> Food truck's gross. >> Shouldn't
off to kids. >> The silence is deafening.
>> I do that.
>> Who's a
>> Well, let's even pretend that. Notice how you didn't
deny that you jerked off to kids. So, why don't we just go ahead
and answer this question right now? You jerked off to kids.
>> Okay, do you jerk off to cartoon drawings of kids?
>> There you go. >> But But notice But notice >> Didn't
Wasn't Wasn't your advice from everybody to not say that anymore?
That was literally the advice everybody is giving you. STOP SAYING
THAT. STOP DOUBLING DOWN on that. Stop. Stop. You got to stop.
You got TO STOP. YOU GOT to stop doing it. >> It's how
But notice how you go after me
>> It's gross. Stop jerking off to cartoon kids. >> I
I I I I'll let you finish. I'll let >> I don't care if
you let me finish. Stop jerking off to cartoon kids. It's [__]
gross. >> Okay, then stop defending Stop defending >> Stop
jerking off to cartoon kids. It's >> By the way, I don't
think Connor defends
>> That's such a Wait. You guys are bringing up like the
most difficult >> really got me. You really got me. I did.
You jerked off to cartoon kids. It's [__] gross.
Stop doing it.
You jerk off to cartoon children. Stop to cartoon children.
Are you going to agree to stop to cartoon children?
Food chops.
>> Connor, is that going to be an actual conversation like
a food >> No, it's not. Uh I'm I'm going to ask you a very
simple question, which is Are you going to commit to no longer
to cartoon children?
>> Dude, Destiny's strongest soldier has one kryptonite,
and it's Could you stop off to kids? And then deathly silent
after that. Me, that's >> yes so we can move on.
>> What the Yeah, I'm totally going to stop, okay? >> Okay,
that's >> Yeah, I'm like totally going to stop. >> Sounds
like sarcasm so I don't believe you. And they just said just
say yes so I don't believe you. >> No, no, he's right.
Instead of to cartoon kids, um I'll just think of you instead,
okay? >> Don't do it. Don't >> You'll just do what?
>> I'll just think of you instead. Is Wait, someone said
>> He He Trust me, Connor's going to think that's much
better. Right? Connor's just going to go, "Oh, thank you. I'm
with adults." That's like weird, but at least, you know, it's
better than the kid thing. Thank you. >> Oh, wait. Can
we I'm here. Okay, so can we move on from the conversation? It
sounds like it's for like stuck at a dead end. Like >> You
don't You don't understand. He doesn't He's too cowardly. He's
too cowardly to actually have a conversation or debate. It's
fine. >> So I'm sorry. What What do you want to talk about
besides the fact that you off the cartoon kids?
>> No, I'm just saying you're a total hypocrite. He is
the one comparing to actual is so crazy. That's so insane. But
yeah, go ahead. >> Raiden, you only said something about
>> kids, you freak. I don't even know why they tolerate
you, man. >> on this over and over and over again. >> Carson,
about >> No, I probably something's about to
>> If I I think I wanted to just if I may if I may like
the counterpoints
um Connor
>> buddy, I understand that
you feel >> He's afraid. He's 100% afraid. >> No,
I felt this way for a year. >> I I know I get it. I get
it. >> I felt this way the entire time. I think you're
disgusting and the fact that you don't you haven't changed your
mind and whenever somebody brings up the fact that you off the
cartoon kids, you just go, "Oh, I said that a long time." You
think people don't notice? You think people don't notice that
you don't rebut the fact that you still engage with
but you said, "Oh, I said this a long time. You think people
don't notice that you're a pedo?
>> No, I Everybody knows. >> I'll think of you instead.
I'll think of you instead. I'll think of you instead, okay? It's
okay. >> That would Well, I'm an adult man, so that would
be a step in the right
>> Hell yeah. See, that's what I'm talking about, see?
Done. Topic done, right? You won't bring this up again? >> No,
I will bring every time you say something I'm going to bring
this up. >> I'll I'll talk to you instead, okay? It's okay.
>> That is a upgrade.
>> That's better. >> See, that's what I'm talking
>> a kid. >> That's an agreement right there. >> Yes,
you talk to adults if you're an >> Wait, let's let's let's
let Wick speak. Let's let Wick speak. Wick speak your >> I
get it, Connor. I do. I think yesterday went Yesterday didn't
have to go how it did. There was a path and I think that there
was a way for everyone to win.
and I get why. I think that you you let kind of your
uh your your just you your feeling of being attacked and under
pressure
>> Dude, what? >> The gaslighting is crazy. But,
okay. >> get you to make decisions that I think >> Totally
not a cult, by the way. Just not cult-like whatsoever. Not a
cult. Not a cult, guys, at all. >> You you didn't have
to make. I >> Yeah, he was crashing out. >> Well,
hold on. I I I want to be fair to CounterPoints cuz I I do sympathize,
right? Like and I I talked to you before
everything happened, like the first time I hopped on and and
I I thought it went well, like hey, I get it. You don't want
to compromise your principles. Um fair enough. Uh but look, there
is a mass amounts of people attacking someone that you consider
a friend. Coming at them come like way beyond just like uh um
making fun of him or critical of his takes, and things like literally
trying to ruin his life. So, he asked you a favor, right? He
asked you a favor like, "Hey, I don't want these people in communities
connected to me." Now, I get it. >> Wait, but Wick, you
literally said no to this. Wick, you literally said no to this.
Wick, you literally said no to this. Wick, you literally said
no to >> You don't want to ban anyone for that? And you
know what? I was able to talk to him the day before and get a
compromise as well. Like, "Hey, I don't want to ban people with
just for for saying things, right?" Like, I don't want to ban
that. But, I was And he was very reasonable with me. Like, so
I don't I don't know why you guys didn't go that route. Like,
why not? What happened?
>> Because I'm not going to accept the implicit threat
of what's being said. >> It's It's not an implicit threat.
Someone asked me for a favor.
that. You know full god damn well, as much as I do. Mutant so
much as confirmed it, that the simple ask of, "Don't allow snarkers
in your community in order to endlessly [__] me."
It never happened in my community. There's no evidence that it
ever happened in my community. You're making this [__]
up whole cloth. And so, the implication is, "Kick these two people
from your community, or else we don't hang out anymore." I've
been hanging out with Steven for six god damn years. I deserve
more than that. And if he doesn't like it, then he can [__]
off.
Sorry, what was funny?
Bro, it's just >> Ignore Ignore food chopped. Ignore food
>> Yeah, ignore me. Ignore me. What was funny? The person
who talked to the cartoon kids who shouldn't have a career at
all? >> Ignore me. You're going to get You're going to
start losing on this. Look, I get it. There were paths where
you didn't have to kick anyone out. I understand that it was,
um, that you feel that it was, uh, and I I I don't hang out with
Cogs, so I can't speak either way to whether it's true or not,
right? It doesn't matter. Um, but there like
even giving him the chance to kind of come in, check every once
in a while, see what's going on. >> He's not the police.
>> He's your friend, bro. >> Yeah, and my friend
should have the balls to allow people to talk [__]
about him on the internet. Or, if he's going to say, "These people
are engaged in a life ruination campaign against me." then they
should be able to produce
And if they don't produce evidence, I'm going to tell them I'm
telling you, you think yesterday was bad? >> The evidence
is TDD by the way. Like like a phrase has been used on the internet
forever.
>> I'm tired now. I just talked to the snarkers for 6 hours.
It's going to be bad tonight.
Okay? Because I'm not going to have this >> Hunter is very
correct. >> it go? Oh, these two people are bad. Remove
them from your community. Okay? Can you produce evidence that
these two people are bad? Nope, you just have to trust me.
>> produce evidence.
You may not have found it sufficient, but that evidence exists.
I can confirm some of it exists. >> So so do we dox you?
>> or not? >> Do we dox you?
>> Again, these people are all connected. It's like a structure
like an ISIS. The the people in >> Do we dox Destiny? >> Dude,
how did we how did we go from like apparently a neutral actor
to totally like at the the tail end of the most cultish in like
2 seconds. I was a neutral actor. These people are all connected.
They're like ISIS. They're like split them split yourselves.
>> do the bombing, but they are still connected to ISIS.
>> asking so you you have you have like a video taped sermon
of Des of Dubi being an ISIS
>> You have to >> So go ahead and please give me
that. >> He's like a propagandist, dude. >> Yeah,
you just said that he's a propagandist. So do you have do you
have the video >> or extended text messages of the propagandist
proselytizing? >> you having you having Dubi on the entire
time. Like we don't even need to look at like Dubi in the voice
chat. Like why do we even need to look at that? You're the one
who had him on. Like what did Dubi say that you think is incorrect?
The way that he kind of moral frauds about Steven, mind literally
every single woman that comes his way. What are you talking about?
>> By the way, I've said multiple times >> I've said
like multiple times I don't think I think he's too mentally ill
they'll use the oh he just targets mentally ill people. I've
like totally changed my my thoughts on that. I used to lean into
that meme. It's not That's not what it is, man. >> Does
Steven not mentally ill women routinely? Wait, who who who do
I got to do hold on let's let's let's start over cuz he's been
going for way too long. What's our strongest example of >> Strongest
example? >> Yeah. How about Britt?
>> I've never met this person in real life in my entire
life. >> Yeah, are you communicating with them right now?
>> They tried to add me on 50 million accounts right now.
No, I'm not. >> Yeah, I know you are. >> Okay, I'm
literally not. I don't have any evidence of that right now. I
bet they probably have things like please add me again. Steven
has >> Wait, who's Britt?
Who's Britt? >> What's the strongest go-to example of mentally
ill women?
>> Okay, pick somebody cherry. Wait, wait, wait, hold on
hold on.
>> It's It's just crazy. There's no way this just said
Britt. I'm sorry. I got to I don't know who that is exactly.
>> Hold on. Lauren Southern >> Oh, you said Lauren
Southern. >> Let's assume that I shouldn't have seen her
the third time, okay? >> No, I don't care about you seeing
these people. Off. Sorry, I >> I didn't want to hang out
with her, but that's fine. But even if J Stoks worse than you,
let's say J Stoks a
>> What does that have to do with you?
>> Yeah, just give that away. Please just give away that
I'm a Connor in the future. Just say yeah, he's a
>> That's what you want. >> J Stoks a
>> Okay, what does that do about you? >> Thank you.
>> That's fine. As long as you acknowledge J Stoks a That's
fine. >> Thank you. Yes. Let's go. I'll just say it's very
obvious that Destiny is incredibly mentally ill. He is the last
person who should ever be stigmatizing other people's mental
illness. >> The He has >> Okay, when did you meet
Britt? You want to play this game? Let's play this game. When
did you meet Britt? >> I've never met this person in real
life >> Okay, when did you meet her digitally?
>> I don't remember. Now, I'm not going to dig through
here and have you audit the lives of people who DM me crazy stuff
on Discord, though. This is not relevant to the conversation.
And this is a new >> relevant to the conversation, isn't
it? >> a new
>> Wow, this is crazy. >> person that you want to
attack me with, Connor, but it has nothing to do with the reason
why you've obsessed
you my life for the past like >> Ah, let's go. >> At
least. You know why? Because you are reaping what you sown. You
are reaping what you've sown and you haven't learned your lesson
and it sucks. >> Okay, in my current court case drama,
who what is the what what is the sown part? What did I sow here?
Was it >> Wasn't immoral for you to have sex with Pixie.
It was immoral for you to take her homemade and send it to somebody
that you'd only known for 10 days. >> Okay, so it was immoral
for us so it was immoral for us to record something or was it
immoral for us to trade it or >> It's immoral for you to
trust somebody you've never met after 10 days with
of your friends. >> Let's assume that's the case. >> Let's
assume that that's true to anybody with a [__] brain.
>> Connor, then why did Pixie okay to share with a woman
she's never even met in her >> Destiny, when I'm I'm not
talking about everybody else. I'm talking about you. >> me
and Melina. >> about you. >> Connor, if me and okay,
hold on. Do you think that Pixie des
>> He's going to do the thing where he compares like Pixie
sorry, Melina who is Destiny's wife, long-term partner, who's
supposedly trustworthy, right? To a sex worker he'd known for
10 days and met on >> reap what she sown? >> Yes,
she's a dumb she shouldn't have [__] shot homemade
with you. >> Does every single person who shoots homemade
have it leak? Are they all reaping what they've sown? >> Destiny,
how about this question? Do you think it's smart to send homemade
to somebody you've only known for 10 days? >> I don't know.
Ask anybody else that question. >> THAT QUESTION.
>> I DON'T KNOW. I DON'T KNOW. WHAT? IT THAT COULD It could
go anyway. IT'S DUDE, IT'S 50/50. >> DO YOU THINK it's
prudent? >> Do you think it's prudent to send homemade
to somebody when you've only known them for 10 days? Yes or no?
>> Sure, Connor. That was the behavior that >> Wait,
you're saying yes, it is prudent? >> Connor, why does this
matter? >> Yeah, why does this matter? Because this has
torched endless professional opportunities for his homie. That's
why >> I don't need recommendations from you, I think I'm
okay professionally. I don't need recommendations from you for
how to run my life. Number one, number two. >> Yes, you
do, you dumb because you keep burning your own life. >> Number
two, I'm not the one >> a [__] social worker.
>> Holy [__] You're so ass pain over your obsession
with my life. >> No, I'm not, you Okay, fine. Shut up.
Shut up. I'll just say it. I'll just say >> After you leaked
homemade After the entire internet hated you, you started with
another woman on Discord. >> Are you serious? >> did
age play with this And she was married to someone else. AND SHE
WAS MARRIED TO A GROPER. SHE WAS MARRIED TO A GROPER.
SHE WAS MARRIED TO A GROPER.
Do you think it is prudent to text message somebody who's married
to a
>> Are these Are these new age play allegations? WOULD
THESE BE NEW AGE PLAY ALLEGATIONS? OH MY GOD. >> I CONNOR,
I'M
>> DO I NEED to pass through every single person that messages
me with a nude or wants to say Is that what I need to Do I need
to get permission from you from now on? Are you going to tell
me how to run my personal life? >> No, but if anybody was
your friend, they would call you an idiot to your face, which
is what I'm doing right now. You are an idiot. You are dumb.
You ruin your own life. >> Okay. All right. Does any of
this >> I don't know what the point If the point here is
for Connor to go, "I don't like the way that you have sex with
people." or whatever. I don't know what the the point is of this
conversation. That's >> Okay, yeah, fine. I'll ask you
this question. I'll I'll make the point abundantly clear. When
you're being sued for leaking homemade should you start text
messaging a woman who's married to a political opposition that
hates your guts?
>> Connor, at this point >> sane or normal behavior?
>> But what I DO WITH MY >> THAT'S going to be So,
why are you saying these people are responsible for doxxing you?
>> How do YOU KNOW IT'S DOOBIE swatting
>> Connor, what I do >> He's going to be himself
as swatted me. Like he's too busy. >> How do you know it's
How do you know it's the Snackers? >> Because these guys
literally have the slogan at the beginning of their [__]
husband. The husband was in a Telegram channel where gropers
were plotting your If they were plotting your then don't you
think they might swat >> I don't know the >> Oh god,
so many things coming together right now. >> You're so
full of [__]
You are so full of This is awesome. full of [__]
You want to blame exclusively
women,
Jay Stok, all of these people for why your life is [__]
up and yet you always poke the bear. You always
YOU IT'S EVERYBODY ELSE'S FAULT. EVERYBODY ELSE'S FAULT. IT'S
NEVER DESTINY'S FAULT. It's never Steven's fault. We can't do
a moral inventory about what the [__] you're doing
every single god damn day. >> Connor, Connor, I don't know.
He got swatted. I don't know. Yes, yes, it is. I want to I want
you to say that. Because I people or a lot of people it is absolutely
everything that's happened to my fault because of that. >> Yeah,
when you try to a married woman of your political opposition
that wants to murder you and then you try to blame people who
hate you on the internet for trying to swat you but then there's
other people who want to murder you too. I'm just saying you're
full of [__] >> Yeah, absolutely. 10 Let's
go. >> your your contention is that this group of people
I guess are they're the ones swatting me. I didn't get swatted
>> more evidence that they're swatting them the swatting
you than you have presented that the snarkers are swatting you.
>> Connor, you have no evidence they've swatted me. >> Yeah,
you're right and yet I still have more than you. And yet I still
have more than you. >> money evidence. >> Aaron,
direct evidence or conflating direct evidence with any evidence
at all. Like obviously this is what he does in his own court
case with the guards of the Abbey testimony. Presents that's
not evidence at all. >> evidence that I have? I HAVE EVIDENCE
THAT HE'S in a panel plotting Steven's murder. But you want to
take all the negativity that's on the internet about you and
you want to tie it to one community.
>> You're full of [__] You're full of [__]
>> Connor, this Telegram group appeared like a year after
my first swatting incident. I don't know why you're pretending
that everything came from that. Is this >> Your first swatting
incident, that was the Trump assassination attempt as in before
all these people hated you. Before you could have blamed the
quote unquote snarkers. You
>> I'm not say You are being obtuse.
I'm saying that >> going to talk just said he does age
play with some new woman and GOOD REASON. >> ALLEGATIONS
BACK ON THE TABLE, BABY.
I'M JUST JOKING.
>> Cope I've ever heard in my entire life. By the way,
do you want to go ahead and reassert your evidence for how the
cog Do you want to reassert your evidence for how the cog is
compromised? Because we have two
snarkers IN OUR DISCORD.
>> WHAT THE
THIS is about This is about This is about
>> It's mind-blowing. >> Connor, I have
I've never in my life said that every swatting attempt or whatever
has come from the H3 whatever the the snarker people the I don't
actually 100% know that. The very first time I got swatted was
after the >> So why do they deserve the doxing?
I thought I I thought Esports Batman, Wicked Supreme,
Jay Stock,
Jay Stock, Queenman, Doobie, I thought they all deserved doxing
because they were complicit in your doxing, swatting, and harassment.
I thought that's why they deserved to be >> No, it's because
they have engaged in a year and a half >> Keep going.
We could just watch your content for the last 6 months and see
you running away from your own talking points.
How are How are you running away from your own talking points
right now? >> Dude, what?
>> Okay, so why did Esports Batman deserve to get doxed?
>> No, I'm going to answer the other question that you
asked me before you try to railroad us. >> By the way,
Connor knows this cuz he was defending the original talking points
and then Desi ran from them. Connor knows that he got pressed
in the original talking points and how much they've changed.
>> question. You said what is my issue with these people?
And I've said it and I've clarified it 50 billion times is that
for a year and a half these people have run a real life long-term
harassment campaign that has encapsulated multiple channels,
multiple Discords, and multiple mediums like websites like Kiwi
Farms and Discord >> Has it been a year and a half since
the court case was announced or since the Yeah, since the court
case was
>> career and my life. That's been my
>> Yeah, and they're stochastically responsible for your
swatting and doxing, yeah? >> Conner, I'm not a baby. I
don't give a [__] if some cops show up to my house
with some guns. >> By the way, like I understand the TDD
thing was a was a thing. We dropped it like within By like April,
it was gone. By March, it was gone. >> What I care about
is if people are getting harassed who are peripheral to me and
my life where people are >> In fact, I think I did a whole
speech on how we're going to move away from the Destiny content
in March. >> Making fun of them. But these people are >> Do
you remember? Do you remember
>> cry about [__] doxing. Swatting is annoying,
I do admit it, and I do consider it a kind of attempted murder,
but I can deal with that. What I can't deal with is every single
person peripheral to my life getting mind I'm watching you. You're
mind right now. That stuff >> Oh, he's basically he's just
saying again, he just doesn't like to talk. He doesn't like that
we talk about him in a negative way. That is what it is, right?
He's just admitting it full out now. Now he's trying to do a
little shift. Little shift while I'm in the room with all the
sick events. Guys, it's just about actually these people talking
about me the whole time. It's that's what it's always been about.
>> worse to me because I have no control over that. I can't
do anything to influence that than than talking about personal
rifles again. >> Do you think J Stalk convinced me that
you engage with like insane behaviors that puts you at incredible
risk? >> Your obsession with Mike has nothing to do with
anything that's happened with the past 2 years. >> Except
for the fact you
that you were
an unstable woman who is still
at this moment
and who was married to your political opposition who wants to
get you.
>> This is Britt, by the way. This is Britt he's referring
to. This is Britt. >> Who Who gave you this idea that this
person is like anything relevant to any of the past year and
a half of real life harassment towards other people I know of
harassment towards anybody following social media of interviewing
court cases of reaching out to witnesses >> He did. >> Oh,
she She said >> unstable woman that you are >> Her
name is it First of all, I'm not talking to this person right
now, okay? Number one. Number two, she said Is that who she is?
>> Sorry, what? >> Is that who she is? Is her name
Sable Sexual online? She's the one who in Just Just Just Just
Just Just Just Just Just Just Just Just Just Just Just Just Just
Just Just
If you are the one who Hold on. I SHOULDN'T CARE ABOUT YOUR SEX
LIFE. WHEN YOU'RE DOING something so reckless and stupid it runs
the risk of you I as your friend shouldn't have criticism of
you? >> The amount of The amount of pivot sweep that you've
done, none of this has anything to do with my court case. You
are desperately running from it because you know that you can't
>> I said that you are a sex
And you're dangerous to yourself. >> Okay. All right. That's
good. That is basically nothing to do with any of the problems
that I've been experiencing for the past 2 years, but unless
I get >> You don't think that you're in a court case right
now because you're a sex and a danger to yourself?
>> Who was the I was recording videos with Pixie. I shouldn't
have done that 6 years ago.
>> I'm sorry. You're almost there. You're almost at the
point that's actually a good point.
>> Yeah, please please don't take the way and how it resulted
in the court case. Please do.
Is you just not liking people having casual sex or doing sexual
play? >> me because I'm a sane adult, I don't like that
my idiot millionaire friend who is wildly intelligent, wildly
successful in so many domains of his life thought that it was
smart to send
to random people on the
That's why I'm calling you Jace didn't tell me that. Weeman didn't
tell me that. Doobie didn't tell me that. I thought that you
were myself and I've called you for 2
And you're still
>> If a Just a fan showed up at my house and me because
they were so upset over the court case, would that be my fault?
>> Sorry, if who showed up and murdered >> Just a
fan showed up at my house and me because they were so upset about
my sex behavior. Would that be my fault? >> How about we
change it to the graper? >> Can Can you ask me Can you
answer that >> No no no I I'll answer your question. If
the graper showed up and murdered you, yeah, that'd be your fault.
>> If one of Just a fan showed up at my house and he hurt
me, okay? Would that be my fault? B- B- But >> I literally
just said I didn't want this guy like destitute tonight, which
by the way took some some meditation to get to that point in
my life, okay? Right? Didn't just want this guy like Like trust
me, it's been a process cuz this guy's been trying to ruin my
life at a lot of different points, okay? Way more than ever I've
ever tried to go after him.
And I've gotten to the point where I'm like, "You know what?
He doesn't have to He doesn't have to get totally
And now he's like, "Oh, THESE PEOPLE THESE PEOPLE WANT to kill
me." >> But if if the if a hypothetical person murdered
you, would that be your fault?
>> No, he's to blame for his life for that. She didn't
say that right away when she first when she first reached out
to me. What do you want me to say?
>> Okay, you're you're literally like The main point is
you are and it destroys your career. >> No, that's not
the main point, you The main point is there's been a 2-year mass
harassment campaign that like you, I guess cuz Who? I'm not going
to be personal, okay? Listen, whatever problems or issues that
you have going on right now, the fact that you are willing to
sweep every thing that these
>> Connor, Connor, you're mentally ill. Connor, you're
mentally ill. Connor, you're like having a crash it. You're mentally
ill, Connor. >> things are doing online because you don't
like the way that I have casual sex is the most insanely petty
watch I've ever heard in my entire life. It's crazy to me.
>> Destiny, I'm not the person being sued for $15 million
for being a
I'm not the person who is getting videos from a groper and his
wife, you
>> Is that why I'm being sued?
>> No, but that's why you're going to get What's your name?
What Where Didn't we have a theory that Rose and the Rose was
like um A solo was a groper and Rose was like That was the early
theory, right? That's what Destiny thought. >> Is that
why I'm Is that why I'm being >> You're being sued for
being 100%.
>> Okay, so just help me draw the line here. So, no more
recording videos or no more having casual sex at all? >> With
adult women being insane. >> Why are you saying adult women?
I'm >> with women THAT ARE 25 TO 40 AND HAVE SEX with people
that you have a conversation with for more than 30 SECONDS. IT'S
SO NORMAL. It's so normal. As many PEOPLE AS YOU WANT, BUT STOP
BANGING PEOPLE WHO ARE [__] crazy.
>> You know what? I had a lot of conversations with you.
You know who I had a lot of conversations with who's pretty close
to my age who's probably more responsible than anyone else? [__]
Lauren Dailly. Good advice. Thank you. >> I'm sorry. What
the [__] does Lauren Dailly Laguna have to do with
you? Another [__] that you [__] who's
crazy who's trying to ruin your life. As a matter of fact, hold
on. That's a great point, Destiny. There's another [__]
that you [__] that's trying to ruin your goddamn
life. >> Let me Let me Thank you for bringing it up. I
forgot about Lauren Dailly Laguna. >> You know what happened
today? Violet Violet texted me today. Violet texted me today
and she said, "Oh man, Steven's going crazy. You know, this kind
of reminds me of uh back what happened with Lauren." And you
know what >> I had to say in response? >> WHICH LAUREN?
>> DUDE, WHAT? OH MY GOD.
That's a crazy
Dude, that's amazing. That's That's >> you've had sex with
two or three of them. And one of them's [__] crazy
and trying to ruin your life. >> Because you're an idiot.
That's That's an easy mistake. There's one Lauren everywhere,
you know. >> North, south, east, west. >> you could
have [__] Chen, you would have [__] Chen,
too. >> This would have been Okay, excuse me. She's pretty
hot. Okay, number one. Number two. The if if the whole thing
is you hate me having casuals, then just say that. And then you
can cut out all the [__] >> I love you and
I want you to stop being >> Oh my god, it's such a cringey
situation. [__] up. >> You say you love me
after every conversation. Did you not mean it? >> I think
that me saying I love you after every conversation is a lot more
casual than whatever weird you're on right now, >> Oh,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Every Dude, we all
know The entire world knows you're >> Reminds me. Hold
on. That actually reminds me. Guys, hold on. That That reminds
me of
A lot of people are like, "Oh yeah, reminds me of when he crashed
out on Lauren." And Connor's response?
Do you have any idea how little that narrows it down? >> What
did the DOXING HISTORY? WHAT DID ESPORTS BATMAN do to deserve
to be
>> over it. Esports Batman cheered on as a Discord server
and gave legal advice to a Discord server that was a that was
harassing
a trafficking victim. Encouraging her to drop my court case because
they thought it'd be an epic own. That's >> They didn't
know she was a sex trafficking victim. Like they they didn't
know this. But that came from the
Byron. Did he dox you, Connor? >> That's No, he didn't
dox me. >> Did he dox you?
>> Did he stalk you?
>> I would consider that stalking, yes.
Uh did he swat you? >> Notice how Connor doesn't respond
to what I >> That is just a insane statement when this
guy reached out like from a good place at first, right? Well,
I think I think he had good intentions in his heart the whole
time and I think the the record will exonerate Cybar. That is
my That is my suspicion. I've not seen the whole record yet,
but I suspect it will cuz Destiny's lied so much about every
other aspect. >> have to run down a checklist. >> Yeah,
because you're talking because people >> talking [__]
about you on the internet is not a good reason to dox Destiny.
Hold on. I just want to hear you say this. I just want to hear
you say this to be clear. People reaching out to the victim of
a trafficking crime in order to harass her and her family to
force her to drop my case. That's just people talking [__]
CONNOR? >> NO, CYBAR COULD be the one person where if you
doxed him, I'd be like, "Eh." But Esports Batman isn't Cybar,
is he? >> Do you think that Cybar exists without a whole
Discord server cheering him the [__] on? >> Okay,
yeah, I I I love this. So so since I'm a snarker now, and since
I enjoy I'm just mind-griefed by the snarkers, now I agree with
them about everything, I should dox Kafka because he enables
the infinite machine based off of your
>> Do you think that >> He's fair game. He talks
to you. He's a lawyer. He gives you legal feedback. I should
him. >> You'd kill him,
>> Sure. Show me show me Kafka engaging in the behavior
that was anywhere near what Esports Batman does. >> You
know what? You know what? No, no, it really it really boils down
to this. >> It really boils down to this.
If you're going to dox people,
have a good reason,
and evidence it. You haven't done that. And if you're going to
have with people, you stop having with crazy people who are going
to ruin life, Connor. Timeline. I'll just repeat that over and
over and over again. I don't want to litigate every detail with
you because I don't give a because what I'm saying right now
is so absurd. And here's the other thing. Here's the other don't
leave. Don't leave. You're like, "Oh, Connor's obsessed with
me."
You know what? Dan and Mouton are
because they would never say this [__] to your face.
>> Many things in life. No, they would, except they do
in real life. They don't have to do a show >> They do.
They do. Then why don't you listen to them, you stupid
Every single one of your friends is consistently telling you
that you are so
that you are ruining your life and yet you are coming to me and
saying, "Connor, you're di- >> Does Dan know about Brett?
Does Dan know about the age play DMs with the Groper? And sorry,
the Groper's wife? The the psycho Groper's wife? Does Dan know
about this?
Has Dan been sweeping for
>> You're obsessing with me. Hold on. So, if I'm obsessed
with you, why are Dan saying the same thing? Is he obsessed with
you? Is Mouton? Is Kyla? Is Lauren?
How many friends >> you have left, by the way? At what
POINT DO YOU GO, "OH, [__] It's me." I GUESS MAYBE
WIVES AS YOU HAVE LEFT, CONNOR. WHAT THE
>> WHAT THE HELL? What the hell, man? >> for 15 years
and I was loyal to one woman for 15 years. HOLD ON. HOLD ON.
LET'S POINT OUT >> That's the closest I've seen to like
the old Destiny right there. The the quickness of the comeback.
That's the closest I've seen to like a spark of any life in this
guy in like 5 months.
>> Stupid what YOU JUST SAID WAS. HOW MANY WIVES DO YOU
HAVE LEFT, CONNOR? I ONLY HAD ONE AND I WAS MARRIED TO her for
15 years and I was loyal to her for 15 years, you
>> Oh, my god. Keep going. Are you good? >> No, I'm
good. Yeah, you're a idiot. You think one 15-year relationship
compares to your entire life of social dysfunction?
That's so I don't even know why you would say it. >> Connor,
weren't we standing outside your house when you were asking me,
"Oh, I should live a life like you now. I should go and have
all this fun NOW THAT I'M FINALLY >> YEAH, AND YOU KNOW
WHAT HAPPENED? I GOT TINDER, I DID one hookup, I was like, "This
is gay and cringe. I'm going to go find a serious girlfriend."
And then I got a serious girlfriend because I'm almost 40. >> Good
for you, Connor. I guess you're just not very [__]
What do you want me to say? That's a personal problem. Don't
take it out on me, Connor.
>> Grow up. You're 40.
>> Grow up. Connor, you are on the internet talking about
>> You are age playing with a groper's
wife.
You are age playing with a groper's wife. >> get details?
We get details?
More details? >> Now, grow
up. >> Respectfully, you have no idea what you're talking
about, okay? >> No, I do. I got the logs. >> From
him and from her. >> Okay. I don't I don't want to out
their business on the internet, okay? But you don't know what
you're talking about. I promise you, okay? >> I HAVE SCREENSHOTS.
I KNOW what I'm talking about. SO, HOW ABOUT YOU JUST GO, "DAMN,
CONNOR, you're right. I shouldn't be accepting
videos from a groper and his wife who wants to murder me. I need
to chill the [__] out."
>> You said you have screenshots. Who sent you the screenshots?
Connor, are we >> I'm not sending you the screenshots of
the [__] groper who wants to grope Destiny. But trust
me, I have them. And the reason why he can't deny it is because
he knows it's true. >> It's because you have a fraction
of the story that is absolutely not worth anything on the internet.
>> what what could you possibly TELL ME THAT IS GOING TO
TELL THAT'S going to be like, "Oh, [__] Destiny was
right. He should have stopped the groper and his wife." >> OH
MY GOD. THIS IS BRILLIANT. What information or context could
you possibly share with me that would change my opinion on this?
>> I am not going to out parts of any conversation like
this that I have with another person or people. You're [__]
>> Jared, his voice is getting so high-pitched. He is so
pressed right >> I'm not even going to
>> No, I'm not. No, I'm not. I see my friend who's a [__]
idiot up and I've tried to be nice about it and that's not working.
So, I'm going to be [__] mean about it. You're
You don't know how to manage your relationships. Anytime anybody
[__] challenges you on anything, even if they love
you, you run away because you're afraid of growing up. You are
not 13 anymore. You are >> What locks somebody in at a
young age? What is like a thing that happens at a young age?
>> Grow up. Grow up.
>> That was rude. That was rude. That was beneath me. You
know Lauren wanted to get back with you? >> That was rude.
She loves you. She wants the best for you. She thinks that underneath
all the sludge and of your [__] up little life, there's
something redeeming about you. And I agree with her, BUT YOU
ARE SUCH A [__]
THAT IT IS IMPOSSIBLE TO be your friend. It's impossible to be
your partner. It is impossible to tell you that you're wrong.
It's impossible for you to take a [__] L.
>> I'm sorry. That's awesome. That was awesome, okay? But
also, am I the only one who can tell that Connor's had this argument
in the shower like a hundred times before this moment? That like
this is borderline scripted from how many times he's run this
argument in his head at this point? Am I the only one I feel
like I can't be the only one. >> a [__] L and
take a goddamn lap. >> Connor, if you want to [__]
L, me and Lauren have been dating for like three months and we
both agreed not to tell you because you asked her out while we
were in the middle of dating. You have no idea what you're talking
about. WE LITERALLY ANYTHING YOU'RE SAYING. >> YES, I DO.
TO COMMIT. You are too much OF A [__] TO
THIS HOT INTERNET POLITICS WHO I DESTROYED MY LIFE FOR IN 2022.
OH, SHE LOVES ME. I NEED TO GO SEE BPD eat. You're a [__]
idiot. You're an idiot.
YOU LITERALLY HAD LAUREN BACK AND YOU DITCHED her for BPD e-girls
because you're so
You are
You don't know anything about my life. You don't know anything
about my PERSONAL LIFE. >> YES, I DO.
DO YOU DO YOU WANT ME TO GET THE SCREENSHOTS THAT I GOT FROM
LAUREN >> are self-destructing right now because I I think
you should >> He's not self-destructing. >> week
off. >> But that's my suggestion. I'm not going to be here
and contribute to you. Literally, you guys you guys are ruining
your life. >> You should take a whole year off. Do you
know Here Here's another thing. Here's another thing. All right,
he's gone. I'll go ahead and share with the people who are watching.
He did mushrooms
that said that he was alone inside his room and he ignored that.
But exactly what the [__] is happening is he can't
take criticism. He can't let people love him. He can't let anybody
get close and he would rather cycle through a roster of BPD e-girls
and slowly destroy his life rather than get his [__]
together and grow the [__] up. And I'm sick of it.
I played nice with it. I'm not playing nice with it anymore.
I'm >> I understand you're angry, Connor. Please please
please. But do you think now's the time to litigate his life
>> when he's literally under attack? It is >> Yes,
it is. Yes, absolutely. >> And he's crying >> You
You think Rick You want to sit here with a You want to sit here
with a straight face and you want to tell me that he should be
raper in his wife while he's ongoing litigation for for for leaking
homemade
That's the appropriate time to [__] with the BPD
e-girls? >> I think that you're you're really angry and
I get it and then I'm not saying you don't have any reason not
to be angry to be angry, right? But like this is not the time.
This is not the place. >> Yes, it is, Rick. It's exactly
the time and the place. >> It is not. >> It's exactly
You know why? Because it's been years. It's been years. No one
will stand up to this and tell him to his face that he's being
And you know what? I don't give a He knows that I'm right. He's
He destroys career opportunities for his own nihilist hedonism.
He could improve his relationships, but he won't. He has opportunities
for deeper relationships and he runs away from them. That. This
is the exact time to litigate it. And by the way, here's another
detail. Hanging out with a Why is his number one defender of
>> His kid is getting doxxed and you're the one blaming
him for hedonism. That is
Why would I talk to you? >> with disconnect. There you
go. There you go. He's out. He's out. He's out. He's out. He's
out. He's out.
>> What a time to be alive. >> What a time to be
alive.
>> Could you imagine? Could you imagine? Oh my god, could
you imagine? I could imagine it. Connor is terrible with >> Was
I muted the entire time? >> That's a crazy question to
ask after you're done everything, man. >> You think I need
to sit around and talk to a I'm not talking to a If you want
to talk to a you go over there. You go talk to the
I'm not talking to the I'm not the only one who feels this way.
Do you understand I'm not the only one that feels this way? Kyle
feels this way. Dan probably feels this way. Mooton probably
feels this way. Lauren Dale Laguna back in the day probably felt
this way. They all feel this way. Destiny
is intelligent.
He's charismatic.
He's funny. He can be generous. He can be gracious. He can be
kind.
There is a
underneath all of the [__]
But he cannot get over his own trauma. He can't get out of his
own way. And he wants to BPD
into the sunset and slowly but surely ruin his life.
I've tried to be nice. I've tried to be I've tried to be calm.
I've tried everything. I've needed to say that for a year. I've
needed to say that for a
>> Connor's been Connor's had some demons, okay? Connor
Connor has some demons going on.
Not to me. >> And you know what? I'll say this >> It's
not to me. >> BPD girl. >> Her message to me is,
"Oh my god, please stop. He's never going to talk to me again."
I just I I truly like despise the whole like um somatization
thing.
It just it it just feels so annoying that I see it.
Like this is I know Connor I know Connor
like to get through to Destiny.
And I know it might seem like it's
But this whole thing of the the BPD e-girl thing, this is only
uh this is a device used to make it seem like they're not human
and they're not important so they can forgive Destiny, right?
That they it doesn't matter. Anyway, we keep >> casually
engages with mentally ill >> Are we way behind on Kick
Chat? >> You're pretty crazy. >> Huge wick tweet.
Oh my holy my
way behind. Hold on.
Oh my my chat's way behind. Hold on. I don't want to talk. What
what why why would I want to talk to you right now? >> Huge
wick tweet. >> Why are you doing this public? This is a
huge wick >> Can he stop [__]
>> That was not the time to scold Destiny for his sex life.
>> Stop YouTube and politics.
He that he hung out with that Nazi
He hung out with that Nazi because he wanted a crumb of Nazi
and then he took it to the America events. He was bringing side
to the America events.
[__] you.
>> Oh, he's unchained. >> Yeah, yeah, yeah. I'm a
pathetic grown Why? Because I won't let my friend endlessly run
his goddamn into a uh a broom over and over again? I won't let
him jump onto brakes in front of me over and over and over and
over again? [__] off.
[__] off. All you
Did you try to Southern what a friend?
I was single. I just got divorced. I like Lauren. I said, "Hey,
are you guys dating? I might ask her out." And he said, "No."
And then I just talked to her as a friend, and then I never asked
her out.
Y'all are so
Y'all are so This man
is being sued for 15
>> No, he's not.
I'm not being sued for 15 million dollars, but whatever. >> He
has spent 800,000
>> Because of what he's done with his
And you're saying, "Who cares?"
You guys are
You guys You guys are literally
the dumbest
on the internet.
Steven's lost 800,000 dollars. Is that not a big deal? Steven
up his relationships with political people. Is that not a big
deal? Steven's lost mainstream opportunities.
Is that not a big deal? Y'all are bad >> Any of the guys
the three guys these guys >> All of y'all. All of y'all
who are in here are like pocket watching, watching, why do you
care? You are horrible >> up so badly, man. >> You
are horrible human beings.
You're pigs. And I'm going to be so happy when you get bored
and leave my stream.
All you
sniveling
worms.
All you worms
in my chat. All you vile,
toothless,
virtueless
sacks of [__] in my chat right now, who would let
Destiny do whatever the [__] he wanted to do as long
as it entertained you. Hold on. >> Apparently we Apparently
Destiny rejoined the call.
>> Uh I just I Wait, wait, wait. Can I just also Can I
just say like a a thing? And I like I know it's all a meme and
a game to everybody, okay? But like it is insane how sociopathic
this group of people is to weaponize people that are either having
extremely crazy personal life stuff going on, which I don't hold
against Connor at all. And listen, we said a lot of mean things
in here, but >> Connor's mentally ill. Connor's mentally
ill. Connor's mentally ill. Connor's mentally ill. >> bunch
of [__] going on in his life, >> Ah, he's sweeping
right now because he feels bad cuz he feels like he's like losing
a number one defender. >> I I just I just want to say real
quick um from my perspective at the very least the doxing isn't
even the same. Like for example, when Destiny doxes it's like
a face dox or it's like >> It's a face dox, yeah. Like
he posted Sal's entire dox. True. >> does happen. But the
thing is is that like when orbiters from Destiny's server it's
their it's their email, it's their address, it's like everything.
Like the doxing >> Unless they're like doing like real
life harm, which I don't think Sal was doing by talking to Pixie.
>> working on doxing. Doxing in and of itself like doesn't
matter. The The thing is what people do with the doxes why people
don't want to be doxed, >> He set up a Darius people, yeah.
>> That's how I got That's not like a DGG chilling Darius
server. >> people who are fighting with people to do, you
know, whatever it is you're worried about. So on their side,
and I know that Duby I think is running around saying this and
I think he even said it to Wick, he might have said it to Connor.
People say these things where it's like, "Yeah, the DGGers are
harassing us all the time." Who? What harassment? Nobody has
done literally anything. Nothing has happened to any of these
people. And they're acting like, you know, them having a name
posted is literally the end of the world. Like meanwhile, yeah,
I mean obviously on my side like not even just me, but like I've
shown DMs of like real life friends of Heather that have gotten
harassed on Instagram and Heather employers contacted [__]
like the idea that it's just not even remotely the same. I don't
know where they get this idea from. >> I tried to ask him
where he was going to get the information from and he misheard
me and it was really cringe, but yeah. >> By the way, Destiny
has posted what he thought was like my dad's obituary to mock
the person's death. I don't know like he's definitely posted
a lot of crazy details that are just
Going to go back to Connor for a second. Watch more Connor. Connor
done? >> I'm done.
I think you mean with Destiny not the stream. Thank you for answering,
but I think you mean with Destiny not the >> I'm not sweeping
for it. I'm not covering it up.
I'm not sweeping for it.
You. Connor, you're projecting. Eat it. Bye. You yelled at your
friend and didn't even listen to him. Do you know Do you know
why? >> I was with my friend.
S- someone Oh, excuse me. Shot homie with a girl.
Shot homie with dozens of people. Met somebody on the internet
for 2 weeks and sent them all the homie and sent them the DMs
of him and a woman he loved.
10 days.
He got sued for $15 million.
He's down $800,000
>> Never got sued for $15 million just to be clear. The
offer was over 150k. It's probably why you said 175 cuz you know
this but you're just >> court case. >> I can point
that out. >> And while he was in the middle of a maelstrom
in which everybody hated his guts. He thought the best thing
to do was to the wife of a griper.
A griper who went on to want
and join a Telegram group. Saying that uh >> Why Why did
Why that? Why did he want to do that?
>> And then he had the [__] nuts to say >> come
to me to my face and to say, "I know it's
I know it's the Snarkers. I know it's
I know it's Queenman and they deserve to be doxxed and harassed.
They deserve to get kicked off the [__] internet.
No, you don't. You don't know that [__] Show me the
evidence.
You don't know that You don't [__] know that [__]
All you [__] in my chat.
You would just let him do whatever the [__] you wanted.
>> going hard. Yeah, you you think I I that for money?
You too.
You know what would be so much easier? You know what would be
so much easier to stay in orbit? It would be so much easier to
be Food Shops. Do you understand that? I could just be Destiny's
loyal little soldier. I could just say, "Oh, Destiny, what are
the talking points today today,
Let me regurgitate them. Let me reinforce them. Let me not think
about them critically at all.
I could be Food Shops. I could be a successful Food Shops. Um
Food Shops.
>> Don't come at me with that happy horse. >> Don't
come at me with that happy horse. Destiny's not a >> Connor
is right. >> like and like that he is a progressive. He
doesn't consider you a friend. You don't have to sweep anymore.
Okay, well, I'm not. There you go. I wasn't >> Are you
sure you're not sweeping, >> I haven't swept in the past
6 hours.
>> Are you sure you're not sweeping,
I feel like Connor would never go all the way into like actually
hurting Destiny. I feel like there's got to be more. >> They
spent years calling you a racist Okay, what the [__]
does that have to do with anything? Connor, is it true that he's
been getting swatted since before the Groypers situation? Who
gives a
The point is that he doesn't know that it's the Snark. >> He's
getting swatted since before the J Stack situation, too. >> But
he wants everybody to go along with the narrative that it is
the Snarkers so he can the Snarkers. That's the point.
You could have listened, Connor, even if he's 100% in the wrong.
Yelling over someone you're trying to help isn't productive.
Well, I've already listened for enough. I've already listened
for long enough. It's his turn to listen. I don't think anybody's
more of a watcher than J Stack, but you'd be close. All right,
here's a 24-hour because I like you, try Go eat a
Can you justify the Groyper wanting to kill him? What kind of
friend thinks that way? Oh, I'm sorry. Somebody [__]
your wife. What do you think the chances are that you're going
to kill them? Is it zero? Is your
Got to start from the start, but when you stated wanted to say
you're awesome, real talk most moral one so far. Thanks.
Do you think that is okay? I don't give a [__] Like,
I don't give a flying I don't give a flying [__]
about people calling you a pedo right now. Can you let me deal
with the thousand losers in my chat?
Like, it's definitely not
>> Just talks like one. >> Who want Who think Destiny
can't do
That's completely Snark talking point and telling of events.
You can ask him what really happened and not believe people who
make stuff and harass him. Shut the [__] up, you
loser.
I need I I need you you don't think that I myself think that
Destiny is a Here's 24 hours. Enjoy it. This is going to cost
us money because we are no longer friends with Destiny. Who cares?
Who cares?
Yeah, I think Connor just bought some new fans. He's got some
new fans after this. This is crazy. Here's 24 hours. Thank you
for not giving the literal platform. You're welcome. You're welcome,
Moon.
Jeff Denson says I'm sorry to see it all go down like this. I
heard you and Kayla try to give him the benefit of the doubt
for so many years and he'll act like you're suddenly a snarker
overnight.
Any of y'all feel like this is the bad timeline? Ever since they
shot her on Bay, brother. It's probably been getting swatted
since 2015, but exactly what Connor just said. The heavy implying
do be and Keemstar and etc. are the masterminds. Yep.
Biggest bump to your viewership? I don't know. On Friday I had
a thousand. Where we at today? What was the peak today? I think
he's more upset about the people outside of himself getting doxxed
and harassed. Yeah, you think so? Yeah, you you think Destiny
has empathy? Shut the [__] up. >> He does it.
He He does not. He does not at all. >> He's a sociopath.
Get the [__] out of